wenn Lorenzo Barone einkauft kommt er
schon jetzt kaum über die Runden mit
seiner Sozialhilfe dem sogenannten
Bürgergeld 780 € sind es insgesamt für
sich seine Frau und seine zwei
erwachsenen
Söhne wenn es nicht reicht lasse ich
Anschreiben weil es sein muss meine
Söhne müssen schließlich
Essen ich schaue welche Angebote es gibt
und die kaufe ich immer um Geld zu
sparen ich würde jetzt ein paar Nudeln
mitnehmen und etwas Soße immerhin sind
sie satt wenn Sie einen tellapasta mit
Soße gegessen
haben doch selbst das Bürgergeld das ihm
wenigstens noch ein wenig Spielraum
lässt soll ihm in wenigen Wochen
gestrichen werden wenn Sie uns das
Bürgergeld wegnehmen wird es das Ende
sein
wirklich die Regierung Meloni hat genau
das für viele Bezieher entschieden seit
August werden die Zahlungen nach und
nach
eingestellt
natürlich vermisst man die Leute die
bisher das Bürgergeld erhalten haben
diese Menschen fehlen vorher hat es die
Wirtschaft ein bisschen
angek boli hat 25000 Einwohner etwa 1200
Haushalte erhielten Bürgergeld das heißt
rund jeder sechste hier lebt direkt oder
indirekt davon bis jetzt wie wird es für
sie weitergehen wie
für
die Familien die früher in der Lage
waren das Essen auf den Tisch zu stellen
und das heute nicht mehr sind ist real
und sie kann
explodieren hier in der Nähe Neapels im
sozialschwachen Süden Italiens ist die
Abschaffung des Bürgergeldes deshalb das
Thema auf den Straßen vielen wurde es
bereits ersatzlos
gestrichen man kann nicht mehr Mia ja es
ist
[Musik]
schrecklich ich war Bezieherin des
Bürgergeldes weil ich körperlich nicht
so viel arbeiten kann ich würde gerne
einen Weiterbildungskurs machen wie die
melonie es anbietet dann würde ich eine
Bescheinigung
bekommen also ich habe fast 200 Stunden
an Kursen gemacht sie lassen uns Kurse
machen und lassen uns unterschreiben
dann rufen wir an immer wieder und
niemand ruft
zurück die rechte Ministerpräsidentin
geor Meloni hat die Streichung des
redititan des Bürgergeldes zur
chefssache gemacht schon im Wahlkampf
ein zentrales versprechen
[Applaus]
wer Bürgergeld kriegt ist von Politikern
vom Staat abhängig so ihre Parole und
ihre Anhängerschaft feierte sie dafür
als Regierungschefin gibt sie sich
moderater doch in der Sache bleibt sie
unerbittlich beim Bürgergeld haben wir
das richtige getan das was wir
versprochen haben festzustellen wer
arbeiten kann und wer nicht die das
nicht können werden weiterhin
unterstützt wer arbeiten kann soll
arbeiten und ausgebildet
werden so werde Arbeit gefördert und
Ausgaben eingespart so Meloni künftig
soll nur Bürgergeld erhalten wer über 60
Jahre alt oder schwerbehert ist oder wer
minderjährige Kinder hat allen anderen
wird es gestrichen die ersten 169 000
Haushalte erfuhren vom sofortigen Stopp
ganz lapidar per SMS ausgerechnet im
August zu Beginn der landesweiten
Urlaubszeit bis zum Jahresende wird es
zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen betreffen
enrika molikio forscht zum Thema
sie sieht die Entscheidung
kritisch ich glaube dass es nicht mehr
Arbeitsplätze schaffen wird sondern nur
mehr Verzweiflung die Stellenangebote
die über die von der Regierung
vorgesehene Plattform kommen sind sehr
sehr wenige und auf jeden Fall helfen
sie nicht dieser Nutzergruppe also den
Beziehern von Bürgergeld denn das sind
hauptsächlich Arbeiter und oft über 50
Jahre
alt vor allem Italiens wirtschaftlich
schwacher Süden ist betroffen dort
demonstriert einige gegen die
Abschaffung in Neapel Arbeit sagen sie
gibt es hier kaum jedenfalls keine
legale Schwarzarbeit bieten sie mir alle
an in Neapel bieten sie das alle an sie
geben dir einen Teilzeitvertrag aber Sie
zahlen dir was Sie wollen wir sagen
nicht dass wir nicht arbeiten wollen wir
wollen ja arbeiten dann bräuchten wir
kein
Bürgergeld so sei es auch in boli sagt
Lorenzo Barone und er zeigt uns die
Situation in seiner Stadt man sieht den
Niedergang
die Wirtschaft ist ziemlich unten es
schließen immer mehr Geschäfte und es
geht so weiter dort ist auch ein
Geschäft das geschlossen hat es sind
viele hier im Süden Italiens ist Arbeit
Rah jedenfalls solche mit Vertrag legale
Arbeitsverhältnisse die es früher hier
noch in Fabriken und Betrieben gab wie
sie Lorenzos Vater noch
hatte die Fabriken wurden geschlossen s
dass wir alle ohne Arbeit daastanden wir
mussten immer herumlavieren wir haben
schwarz gearbeitet bevor ich Bürgergeld
bekam habe ich als illegaler Parkwächter
gearbeitet wo man Hilfe und
Unterstützung bietet kommen jetzt mehr
Menschen auch in der Hauptstadt die
Hilfsorganisation Nonna Roma betreibt
hier im Osten ein Sozialkaufhaus in
einer Gegend wo viele Bürgergeld
beziehen die kaufen hier mit einer
Spezialkarte ein das erleichtert die Not
ein wenig dass die Regierung nun das
Bürgergeld streicht spüren die
Mitarbeiterinnen
seit September merkt man das schon wir
hatten ja schon vorher Leute die zu uns
kamen die zwar Bürgergeld oder Minijobs
hatten aber dennoch unsere Hilfe
brauchten um bis zum Ende des Monats
über die Runden zu kommen jetzt wird es
für diese Familien wirklich eine
Katastrophe wir sind sehr
besorgt in boli gilt für Lorenzo Barone
noch eine Galgenfrist bis Ende des
Jahres weil er im Auftrag der Gemeinde
täglich einen Park sauberhält zusammen
mit anderen bezieh
Sozialstunden das ist eine Arbeit die
uns würde gibt und wir helfen der
Gemeinde mit der Arbeit in dem sozialen
Projekt denn unsere Gemeinden sind in
einem schlechten
Zustand bald wird ihm beides verloren
gehen ab Ende des Jahres gibt es für ihn
kein Bürgergeld mehr und diese Arbeit
verliert er
auch wenn Sie uns das Bürgergeld
wegnehmen nehmen Sie uns die würde wir
wissen dann nicht was mit uns
passiert ganz normal Arbeit legal eine
Anstellung statt staatlicher Hilfe das
ist lor sich eigentlich wünscht hier in
barcoli im Süden Italiens wird sich das
kaum
[Musik]
erfüllen